everybody welcome to Stahl of our
episode four
in this episode I've got the map again
and I'll be working on the supports of
the coaster and that's pretty much also
it I'll be supporting just about half of
the layouts today going kind of in
detail and trying to go for these
realistic girl hour supports which are
quite bulky and complicated so it'll be
an interesting task to accomplish for
sure and as always I've got with me Rudy
heyyo and Oprah - hello so yeah this is
a quite an interesting episode because I
have no idea what we can even talk about
really but to give a bit of an
introduction for the uninitiated girl
our coasters are quite well known for
their ridiculous support structures and
these infinity coasters specifically if
you look at Karen on in Hansa Park it
has some extreme structures around the
first elements but some other examples
would be probably the smiler with
supports going just about everywhere and
a lot of the inspiration for me actually
came from gold rush in slow harden and
to me what all of these coasters kind of
have in common is that they all seem
very over supported and I'm sure that
they're an engineered in such a sense
that the support work is just rights but
compared to coasters from other
companies it really feels like they have
a lot of supports I don't know how you
guys feel about that well I'm just
looking at one of the Hansa Park images
and Wow holy heck this looks like like a
modern art statue that that you know
right one of these New York City modern
artist guys would have placed at some
Beach port or so just to be very cool
wow this is like I mean I have one
question though maybe you can fill this
even in in this episode yeah kind of
filling the time in basically because I
was always wondering while you were
talking about this now when I did the
supports in East Nepali many people in
the comments were actually talking about
how the weight and how the forces are
I've put onto the supports and if I look
at this
they don't really follow a certain
geometric structure it even seems like I
don't know how would they even kind of
spread the whole forces across each
other is there a kind of a rule do you
know anything about that because for me
it looks like super weird as you just
said like like putting them everywhere
but I mean they want to have less
vibrations I guess so that should be
your main target right yeah you want to
keep the track up in general and not let
it fall down by gravity I mean if there
is there's a general rule that's really
easy to follow that works just about for
any coaster it's that they are related
to the g-forces so in areas where you
have a lot of positive g-forces
especially at the bottom at the valleys
between hills you'll get many supports
very high density of supports whereas at
the top of hills
especially inversions or top hats or
things like that you don't really need
that many supports because you know
there's no weight pulling down onto the
track and in fact if you've got negative
G's the coaster car is actually pulling
the track upwards so actually one of the
craziest things that girl hours
sometimes does and I know this you can
see this on hang time and a number of
other girl our coasters I don't know
which ones but you'll see supports
between track pieces so supports that
aren't connected to the ground but
simply a metal beam between one track
piece and another one usually quite high
up where the g-forces are pointing
toward the sky just to keep the track
you know in place generally so it's not
quite as necessary as the supports on
the the valleys between the hills where
you really need a lot of supports to
support the the weight of the car is
pulling down with the positive g-forces
and I think you can kind of tell on the
supports that have done so far the the
top-hat supports were based on the toe
pads of gold rush it's pretty much a
carbon copy so I'm pretty sure that
should work well these top hats are very
similar but as you might be able to see
the top of the top hats as well as the
top of the inversion which I'm
they working on is completely
unsupported and pretty much just
floating in the air
Wow okay this is really that's seriously
a cool cool thing to talk about it
because we were just talking about our
quickly in advance of this episode does
that there's a video on YouTube now
talking about your recreation of Terran
by the way operator and it's very
interesting because there has been also
a little bit of talk about the coaster
itself and how the different coasts of
building mechanisms are kind of styles
in Planko are also kind of doing
different shaping which then eventually
leads to different supporting which is
to me seems to be like a science right
it's it's I mean it's a game but you end
up doing such a crazy amount of research
in terms of how forces would work and
stuff like that I wonder if there will
ever be a game that really considers
this oh it's just even a thing in no
limits maybe I have no idea to be honest
but do we need to support that according
to the forces that would be interesting
to see that kind of the riding behavior
of a coaster would change according to
where you place the supports you know
where I'm trying to go here mm-hmm
I don't think do they have something
like that I mean the game definitely
calculates forces and you know works
with that so no limits allows you to
automatically Bank the coaster track
based on the amount of lateral forces to
make the lateral forces zero so it can
definitely take forces and work with
that but support work is pretty much
just a manual job and it's just you know
have pretty much just going for whatever
looks like it be realistic and be able
to support the track but I don't think
there's quite a as hard of a science
behind it okay yeah because because I
was looking into into your recreation of
Terran apart-er quite a bit like
seriously because for once as a German
I'm really interested in German parks
but also because I was looking into the
other recreation that has been done by
our German friends and this is seriously
insane to talk about all because you
obviously copied the support work that
Fantasia line has done right so yeah and
it's just one one on one copy of
everything yeah this is really
interesting
because some of them even for me look
like weird if you know what I mean and
yeah but it's very interesting to look
at how people do support works when you
do kind of a I don't want to college
fantasy coaster it's it's you know as
long as you are within the region of
trying to build realistics coasters
these are kind of causes that try to be
as realistic as possible but still I
have always the feeling that they seem
to be so much better in support work and
extra coasters and this was the same as
I was opening Turin again I was like
they are all over the place how does
this even work and it feels like they
have even and I think this is a good
thing to talk about for our series see
here they even tried to I don't know
maybe go for more theory than placing
supports in the exact same way and then
just try to find a workaround to make it
work with the scenery if that makes
sense
mm-hmm and so this could be all the
thing for this series over here because
I know that we've been had a kind of
funny chat when you were sending in the
first pictures of your support work and
operator was initially going well and
where do we put the buildings yeah but I
think we're going to do the scene
teaming and buildings in the middle of
the coaster so I guess just like at work
mm-hmm
yeah this what I just meant so I'm kind
of building the scenery in favor of the
support or vice versa I'd seriously love
to know more about that if there's even
a thing
yeah it's extremely difficult yeah like
I mean our cased is more or less
simulate this because I built just the
supports for the first few elements and
then I sent some pictures through
discord and then operator realized that
he had some different scenery plans
which I totally ruined then yeah but
this just really made me realize how
difficult it is to you know manage the
this this structural engineering part of
rollercoasters building these supports
figuring out where the layout goes and
the theming and scenery part of it in
especially in the case of Terran because
just everything in Terran has had to be
managed so well between different
companies you know there's a company who
does the rock work there's a company
that does the architecture is a company
that makes a Terran but then there's
another
company that makes rake you know there
are so many different parties involved
in how they somehow managed to get all
of that scenery and support work to
perfectly work together
it is absolutely mind-boggling I I have
no idea how I did that
exactly and don't forget about the
gardeners for example like oh yeah this
is again something that is completely
crazy and talking about Fantasyland have
you seen the like these pictures also a
fly because this is I think this is even
going to top Tehran in terms of scenery
and stuff yeah I consider Sheila's it's
simply ridiculous and yeah just
following on your point I don't know how
this works
I mean oh wait a second but you are even
recreating it at the moment over to
aren't you yes yes well I'm trying to do
whatever that's that we can find with
pictures so mm-hmm Esther already I mean
I've seen quite a few that are giving
quite a good idea in terms of layout but
is there anything else already so like a
kind of sky view or like a birth
perspective of it not really right now
no but it's only someone who made the
sketch based on the pictures on top of
like a Google Earth picture okay I'm so
happy that I just I like we just
explained a certain artist of frontier
that we need a flying coaster that has
been launched in the game I'm pretty oh
yes I already asked that that many times
but frontier keeps ignoring me so never
mind
yeah well this new generation for comas
in general they're also amazing true
yeah but I wonder I think especially
with that new kind of flying coaster
which hasn't been seen anywhere else
like literally the first installment of
this kind I think even the coaster track
with the launch system would be that big
of an issue I think it's more the issue
like how will you get the people
boarding because they have a completely
new boarding system which is like 90
degrees rotated I think is this also I
think some PMS do have this as well
right oh this is completing you know
it's new it's completing you
well see that's okay so this is also why
it kind of gets very very very crazy at
a certain point I guess because if it
goes into the station you need to have
like a control when the coastal train is
going to rotate 90 degrees and then to
be like you have a system where the
seating is opening exactly that way so
you need to have a positioning of the
entrances especially at certain points
and I wonder if this is even working
with the planet coaster station design
yeah I've no idea but I think they can
they can just make a version that's not
with the turning seats
I guess because they shouldn't they
shouldn't exactly copy the coaster as
the coaster our notes based on real-life
coasters anyway right mmm they pretend
to the Pretender say yeah it's weird
thing to be honest if I might jump on
here I I kind of feel that pretty often
in the past we had these discussions
going on when there was a certain
inaccuracy about a coaster because you
can mostly clearly tell which kind of
course it is based on in reliance yeah
so I think it's always kind of difficult
for them because obviously I'm quite
sure that for the most part they do know
about the little inaccuracies they put
in but I can still not completely
understand tell if it's really because
they need to be a little bit off or if
not because at some points they are so
super accurate that I'm even wondering
if this can be like legal you know maybe
in some other part a quite off so I
don't know maybe it's it's just this
little thing that I need to be a little
bit off at some points to make sure that
they don't ya go in too much with
copyright infringements but I have no
clue
makes sense although I can also not
really imagine a coaster manufacturer
wanting to sue a video gaming company
too soon for putting their cars into the
game I mean at the end of the day
coaster manufacturers aren't actually
super huge companies and I know for
instance that No Limits has got the
rights to use all of the different cars
that they're using in their program so I
don't know it's not quite as
strict's it seems like the industry
isn't quite as strict when it comes to
using copyrighted materials then let's
say that the movie industry is although
I'm completely an amateur when it comes
to this I'm really not so sure about it
well but I think you have a point here
because the movies industry like
especially Hollywood they are like
ridiculous
I even feel they have more lawyers
employed than actual cameramen so yeah
this I don't know it's yet I remember
back then when Facebook had this weird
thing like you know exchange a profile
image with a hero of your childhood
thingy and basically like half of the
world were taking Disney pictures and
they were like yeah well but we have to
put our lawyers out now and kind of put
everyone on the spot now which was I
don't know it was just freaking Facebook
yeah coaster manufacturers definitely
don't have anywhere near enough power
nope by the way you were just talking
about doing only supports but I like
what you did with the bunkers with these
little over and yeah I like this quite a
bit this really went into what I was I
oh yeah trying to do there and then just
eventually stopped because I had done
too much already
so yeah nice that you just followed on
doing this very cool oh yeah I'm glad to
hear about that yeah you always need
something if your coaster track is kind
of going very low to the ground and
going through these little lower lying
areas not to mention putting some
foundations in there
because you always need some kind of
support for coasters so yeah
I thought it'd be just about fitting
although then again this this is really
difficult because I'm mostly doing the
coaster related stuff and then you guys
are adding more of the scenery around it
so we really need to now figure out how
that whole partnership is going to work
so I'm keeping all of this scenery quite
minimal and you guys can still change a
lot about it and for now the current
plan is to keep the area around the
station support las' so that I can build
the supports around the scenery or
through the scenery in some way or try
to make that work together a bit better
that sounds awesome so operator do you
have already some plans for the next
stop in this series yeah yeah different
plans but yeah I can only do one in one
episode so I think I'm going to make and
kind of building entrance for the
factory like where people come in and
like a disk or office entrance kind of
right yeah I not sure on what site I'm
going to place it because the guests
entered the factory near the ducts so
yeah I still have to see what I where I
place the entrance of the factory yeah
actually I mean that will be a cool
challenge for then the next and next the
next episodes to see where you put that
in and then just kind of you know go on
building off of that so I am really
curious to see what you're doing yeah I
agree it's actually a really good idea
sorry to keep coming back to Estonia but
we were into that when we were going to
the huge factory over there there's also
like this separate building where the
people get into the factory and it's
it's almost like a theme park entrance
gate because these factories have
thousands of workers who would go in
there every day so you know it's really
something you have to manage
realistically oh yeah true and didn't
they even get just in the past paid by
like the day they even were working if I
remember correctly so that's also a huge
kind of struggle in terms of paying
everyone when he's leaving at the
factory so oh yeah totally
that's actually pretty interesting yeah
yeah so that's basically the end of the
time-lapse I know it wasn't too much
interesting going on when it comes to
building supports although if there's
just a few things then I still want to
mention point out that I've been doing
alongside just putting the supports
which are mostly at the bottom of these
valleys and then for some of the
elements
I thought the inverting loop the the
non-inverting loop supports work we're
kind of interesting following something
very similar to a lot of non inverting
loops in real life where the supports
kind of Bend around
the Cosa tractors try and keep the whole
loop in position and then something
which some people tend to forgets but
it's actually quite important the
flanges which is all of those sections
which split up the different support
pieces so you know realistically these
supports would have to be transported
into the park and put together as if
they were connects pieces so you need to
put those flanges in there and make sure
you can connect them realistically so
yeah that's basically what goes into
this I quite like it I have to say I
really liked the episode because it's
something different and I I just like
that there is always like a little bit
of a difference between these episodes
to keep it interesting and you know not
always see the same stuff again and I
actually love this because it really
gives a good idea of what we can do with
it mm-hmm yeah good work I also like
that the course you you use for the
supports oh yeah
Oh awesome thank you so much well
that'll be it for this episode then and
next episode it's gonna be operator
again rights yes for the entrance
building yeah all right
so looking forward to seeing that one
thank you guys all for watching and both
of you for coming here and being with me
here for this commentary thanks you're
well short bye guys good bye bye
[Music]
you